hi I'm Eric Foss in dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness is hands down
normal phase for wildest announcement
and is the release I am most excited for
guys madness is in the goddamn title not
only are we getting a real multiverse in
the MCU it's not some tepid lame
multiverse like ooh what if oceanic 815
didn't crash on the island a flash
sideways timeline where Jack has a son
cool now we're talking a gnarly bonkers
multiverse where characters fall into
bottomless acid trips and battle
Lovecraftian nightmare demons like it's
almost impossible to say the title of
this movie without doing it in the voice
of Rob Zombie dr. Strange's when this
horny hell trip was announced at Comic
Con director Scott Derrickson said that
he planned to embrace gothic horror for
this sequel saying that it would be the
MC whose first scary film now we know
that Scarlet Witch will appear in the
film and I have speculated that martial
Ollie's blade could cameo in it to set
up his future solo movie and I think
that looking deeper into the directors
hints and into the exact wording of this
title we might actually get some clues
for this Doctor Strange sequels plot and
how when it comes to the broader Marvel
Cinematic Universe this might be the
most crucial chapter of phase 4 spoiler
warning in case any of my speculation is
too accurate or if my rob zombie
impression haunts your dreams okay when
this new movie was announced like many
of you I was struck by the title this
movie not just how [ __ ] badass it is
but by its specific phrasing two words
in particular stood out first madness of
course because it feels like a nod to
the Lovecraftian influences of the
Doctor Strange comics the author HP
Lovecraft is known for cosmic horror
abstract impossible to comprehend cosmic
beans with crazy names like Cthulhu or
Nyarlathotep yeah they're not easy to
say they lumen from the depths of space
or the endless gloom of the sea with a
mist of the mountains the immensity of
these monsters in the abstractness of
their anatomies often led the humans who
witness them to lose their mark
their psyches chattering the creatures
represent the human fear of the unknown
how for us when concepts are too large
or too overwhelming or too abstract for
us to grapple with that's when we snap
so you can see how Lovecraft was such a
big influence on dr. strange two comics
and Steve Ditko's brilliant psychedelic
artwork that build those pages and scott
derrickson first Doctor Strange movie
the way strange is magical mystery tour
through the multiverse an encounter with
Dormammu in the Dark Dimension were
illustrated and with a title like
multiverse of madness derrickson is
doubling down on this idea presented in
the first film that the MCU multiverse
is so vast and impossible to comprehend
that it requires a brilliant mind like
the one of dr. Steven strange to process
digest and navigate all at the risk of a
descent into madness and indeed many
have observed that in the multiverse of
madness fares a close similarity with
Lovecraft's at the mountains of madness
a novella about an expedition to
Antarctica where they find mountains
taller than the Himalayas that hide a
lost civilization of ancient creatures
called the elder things so this could
actually be a hint to dr. strange to
story perhaps strange discovering more
Dormammu like beings hidden in a
parallel dimension once inspired by
creatures like chiffon who in lore left
behind a spell book called the dark hold
which is a book that has shown up in the
MCU and agents of shield this could be
how they tie in Scarlet Witch and since
the dark cold played a role in the
establishment of vampires it's gonna be
also how blade connects now the other
word that stood out to me in the title
was just two letters long in it's an
unusual choice because if you think
about it most serialized film sequel
titles use an and structured like Harry
Potter and the order of the Phoenix or
as we've seen more recently a : four :
Ragnarok Avengers : in-game spider-man :
far from home
Colin : Hanks just looking around really
the idea is separating the two parts of
the title the overall series name and
then the title of that chapter of the
series so by comparison Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness is kind of
one complete idea like one image it's
kind of like die hard with a vengeance
or The Mummy Returns but Derek's ins use
of this structure doesn't feel
accidental or even an attempt to subvert
Hollywood movie title trends shortly
after the announcement he
actually reacted to someone pointing out
the similarity between his title and the
title of John Carpenter's 1994 film in
the mouth of madness in the mouth of
madness is a story about a book that
causes readers to go insane it's got a
lot of cool stuff in it an otherworldly
New England town a deeper conspiracy
about ancient beans and alternate
dimension I mean to reclaim earth
there's a lot of Stephen King stuff
going on here there are also a lot of
big meta reveals that make you feel kind
of insane as you're watching this movie
it got mixed reviews limited box-office
success when it came out it's a bit
bonkers sure but it is exactly the kind
of cult classic that you could see
directors like scott derrickson being
inspired by as he goes deeper into an
MCU multiverse with infinite layers as
well and the more you look into Derek's
ins Twitter feed lately the more
possible influences begin to show up
let's break them down and make this
episode and official new rock stars okay
once we to point out is Derek's ins
retweet of another account reacting to
the announcement with an HP Lovecraft
quote searchers after horror haunt
strange four places this possibly
suggests that strangest journey deeper
than the multiverse will cause him to
encounter some scarier Lovecraftian [ __ ]
nightmare has been mentioned as a
possible villain and actually Derek
someone a nightmare to be the villain of
the first movie nightmares a demonic
entity from the dream dimension who
feeds off negative emotions of humanity
while we sleep now others have noted
that nightmare is typically associated
with the color green and the red color
palette of this title suggests that we
might be looking at more of a hellish
entity may be like Mephisto the Marvel
entity associated with the devil
derrickson also likes to tweet rock
lyrics as captions to Doctor Strange
comic panels like this recent quote from
Bob Dylan's narrow way and a panel from
strange tales 138 and I comic dr.
strange confronts eternity and asks for
the power to defeat Dormammu to save his
master but eternity decreases strange
already has the means to do so ends with
a battle with more dough now more dough
was set up as the villain at the end of
the first film or ver he was seeking to
kill all practitioners of mystic arts
this could imply a conflict between them
in the multiverse of madness and one
last post I'll point out is Derek's ins
recent retweet of his earlier March 14th
post a quote from Jim Morrison of the
doors expose yourself to your deepest
fear after that
you were free and it's captioning the
cover of Doctor Strange volume 2 number
4 and that is shoe strange ventures into
the land of the dead and fights the
embodiment of death itself perhaps to
suggest a multiverse of madness story in
which strange encounters these souls of
the Fallen in another realm characters
like the ancient one but also Tony Stark
Natasha Romanov Loki whatever constitute
a vision soul or maybe Derek's is just
planning a sick fight scene set to break
on through to the other side neither
case I am Dean for that madness comment
down below with your thoughts on Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at ei
vas and subscribe to new rock stars or
breakdowns and theories about everything
Marvel thanks for joining me I love Rob
Zombie ding-ding-ding-ding-ding
[Music]